How do we solve problems
involving massive pulleys using
Newton's laws?
As a simple example, let's
look at this problem,
consisting of a block
of mass m1 hanging
from a massive pulley that
has a moment of inertia I
and radius r.
We'll find the acceleration
of the block, a1,
and the angular acceleration
of the massive pulley, alpha.
It is critical to remember
that the first step in solving
these problems is to define
the positive x and y directions
and the positive
direction of rotation.
In two-dimensional
problems, you're
free to find any
direction to be positive.
Here, we'll set our positive
x and positive y like this.
Once we pick x and
y, the direction
of the positive rotation
is now also defined
by the right-hand rule.
You'll see shortly that
defining positive directions
at the beginning will save you
from a negative sign nightmare
later on.
Now let's break down Newton's
laws for the different parts
of the system.
First, for the block, we will
write down the linear version
of Newton's second law.
For the sum of forces, we
have gravity pointing down
and tension pointing up.
According to the convention we
just defined, T1 is positive
and m1g is negative.
Notice that since the
block is accelerating,
T1 minus m1g is not 0
but is equal to m1a1.
Notice that here we've set the
signs for tension and weight,
but we don't yet know which
were the block is accelerating.
So we just start
by writing m1a1.
And if, in the end, we
get that a1 is negative,
we'll know that it's
actually accelerating
in the negative direction.
Now let's look at the pulley.
Newton's second law
in its rotational form
is tau is equal to I alpha.
For a normal pulley,
the string is always
tangential to the
side of the pulley.
So r and f are
perpendicular, so that means
the torque is just T1 times r.
What's the sign of this term?
Well, according to the positive
direction that we defined,
this torque is positive.
Again, we'll leave the
sign of the I alpha term
to be positive.
And alpha will turn out to be
either positive or negative.
Finally, we need to connect
these two equations.
Because the block is
connected to the pulley using
an ideal, taut,
inextensible rope,
a1 is going to be
related to alpha.
We just need to figure out
exactly how they're related.
In other words, we need to write
down the constraint condition.
Let's say that the
block hypothetically
is moving upwards.
In this case, what's
happening to the pulley?
It must be spinning
clockwise to pull the rope up
as the block goes in, so it has
a clockwise angular velocity,
which, according to our
convention, is negative.
In fact, if the pulley
rotates a full turn
in the clockwise
negative direction,
the angle changes
by negative 2 pi,
and 2 pi times r of the
rope will be pulled up.
So we can write that delta y is
equal to negative r delta theta
or, taking some derivatives,
a1 is equal to negative r
times alpha.
After setting the
sign conventions,
writing Newton's laws for
different parts of the system,
and then writing down
the constraint condition,
we have three equations
and three unknowns
for which we can now solve.